[Musica]
quante volte nella vita avete pensato
che una cosa fosse bella
Ma vi siete mai fermati a pensare al
perché la vedevate bella
[Musica]
sulla base di cosa dentro di voi è nato
quel pensiero
[Musica]
nel mondo dell'arte il concetto di bello
è qualcosa che mi ha sempre affascinata
e incuriosita mi sono sempre chiesta
come certe persone fossero così
entusiaste nell'acquistare opere che a
volte sembrano così assurde e
concettuali risultare quasi
incomprensibile Eppure ciò che ci
avvicina a un'opera d'arte piuttosto che
a un'altra è proprio il vedere la
bellezza in quell'opera
[Musica]
quando mi chiedono che lavoro faccio e
dico che sono un artista so cosa tutti
si aspettano che io rappresenti la
bellezza su una tela su un quadro o
attraverso un'altra creazione
la prima volta che mi hanno
commissionato un Morales Ero
terrorizzata avevo paura di sbagliare di
fare un enorme macchia sul muro di
guardare quelle persone che avevano
riposto la loro fiducia in me e vedere
nei loro occhi la delusione
le prime volte che Dipingi è Come
mettersi a nudo davanti alle persone
facendo vedere cosa hai dentro
è un atto che espone la parte più vera e
interiore di te sottoponendola al
giudizio altrui in questo modo però non
viene giudicata solo l'opera ma anche la
persona che l'ha realizzata nella sua
sfera più intima per questo credo serva
molto coraggio per mettersi a nudo ma è
anche un atto liberatorio che rivela una
parte di te attraverso un'impressione
sul muro rappresenta la te di quel
giorno la stessa te che il giorno dopo
cerca di nuovo di uscire attraverso il
pennello ed è così che negli anni è
diventato qualcosa a cui non posso più
rinunciare
[Musica]
ognuno di noi da bambino ha riempito
fogli di colore pittura esprimendo
liberamente se stesso e la propria
creatività senza alcun vincolo ma la
maggior parte delle persone crescendo ha
smesso di dipingere E perché avviene
questo
ho riflettuto su questa domanda e credo
che il motivo principale sia la paura
del giudizio altrui
se la pittura È espressione di se stessi
forse si smette per paura di sentirsi
dire che quello che si è fatto è brutto
e questa paura è sufficiente a frenarci
dal prendere un foglio una tela o
addirittura un muro e iniziare a
dipingere qualcosa
[Musica]
credo che a un certo punto della vita
ognuno di noi smette di esprimersi
davvero liberamente come faceva da
bambino omologandosi alle persone o alle
convenzioni sociali e spesso reprimendo
quello che ha davvero dentro di sé
[Musica]
quante volte ci soffochiamo con una vita
talmente piena di impegni da non
lasciarci il tempo per pensare a chi
siamo e alla strada che stiamo
percorrendo una frenesia che non ci
lascia il tempo di capire se siamo
davvero sulla strada giusta
[Musica]
la pandemia in questo senso è stata una
doccia fredda per tutti
ci ha costretti a stare davvero con noi
stessi e ad autonalizzarci per qualcuno
è stato come l'occasione per fare pace
con una persona con cui non si parlava
da anni avendo il tempo di chiarire che
cosa funzionava e cosa no è stata
l'opportunità per tante persone di
reinventarsi di trasformare una passione
in qualcosa di più grande di esporsi
attraverso i social di affrontare la
paura di essere giudicate credo che a
tutti noi servisse un momento nel quale
fermarsi completamente e ragionare per
capire che la vita può essere ancora più
bella se vissuta inseguendo le proprie
idee le proprie passioni i propri sogni
questo Rende ogni giornata parte di un
disegno più grande uno scalino che ci
porta nella giusta direzione per noi
verso ciò in cui crediamo
[Musica]
per me dipingere questo esplorare me
stessa attraverso i pennelli e ricercare
le bellezze in ciò che faccio ogni
giorno ma ho capito che la bellezza è
soggettiva ci ho messo un po' a
realizzare perché le persone hanno
sempre opinioni divergenti sulle mie
opere Ma ora mi è tutto più chiaro
ognuno di noi guarda Un'opera come uno
specchio
[Musica]
ogni colore tratto o movimento smuove
qualcosa di diverso in ciascuno di noi
che può essere legato al passato o
all'esperienza vissute ma anche allo
stato d'animo del momento presente
ogni opera smuove qualcosa in noi e
secondo me la vera chiave per un artista
non è tanto il suo talento quanto
l'empatia la capacità di riuscire a
capire le emozioni che prova la persona
a cui è destinata all'opera stessa e
tradurle in una forma
[Musica]
l'arte per me è questo è capire Ogni
giorno me stessa e chi Ricerca le mie
opere scavando a fondo e creando così un
linguaggio puro e autentico dove il
pennello diventa il canale delle nostre
emozioni un mezzo che le fa uscire e le
imprime in un'immagine è per questo che
L'arte è per tutti è qualcosa di
fruibile attraverso il linguaggio
universale dei sensi e quindi tutti noi
possiamo vedere della sua bellezza
[Musica]
si tende ad associare la figura
dell'artista ad uno stereotipo ben
definito ma vorrei sfatare questo mito
ognuno di noi credo che a suo modo possa
essere un artista la creatività la si
trova ovunque in ogni professione in
ogni azione che si compie con impegno e
passione
per me ritornare a vivere è questo saper
riconoscere il valore di ogni piccolo
gesto che si compie per realizzarsi
non è solo una questione di vita sociale
o di poter ritornare alle attività di
tutti i giorni la vita è piena di cose
belle che spesso ci sfuggono ma penso
che la chiave per vedere la bellezza se
cercare la piena Armonia dentro di noi
perché solo mando ciò che abbiamo dentro
riusciremo ad amare ciò che attorno a
noi vedendolo totalmente
incredibilmente bello
[Musica]
[Applauso]